mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
ist die welt am ende
[Musik]
nein so weit ist es noch lange nicht
doch eine ausstellung im
naturhistorischen museum bern erzählt
vom weltuntergang
wie passend
fanden wir
[Musik]
ja geschlossen wie alles in diesen tagen
aber mit uns kommen sie trotzdem rein
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz wir
machen heute station hier im
naturhistorischen museum in bern und die
aktuelle schau verspricht weltuntergang
ende ohne ende
also keine bange so schnell geht sie
nicht unter die welt kann sie mit bevor
wir hier reinschauen zu es noch unser
aktueller bericht von den
kulturschaffenden und wir es ihnen geht
in zeiten von corona
seit 30 jahren arbeitet ruth erz als
kunst fotografin lebt von einem projekt
zum nächsten bisher hat es immer
gereicht doch jetzt sind alle ihre
ausstellungen abgesagt und neue projekte
durch die krise nicht in sicht unklar
ist wie sie sich nun finanziert also ich
persönlich bin mir abgewöhnt drei
sicherheit auch im kunstkontext muss man
könne mit dem laptop er sich hätte tages
neues loser voßhans wieder beschlossen
hat zwei sätze erfasst oder und das ist
die künstlerin steht stellvertretend für
die kulturszene in dieser krise
bedroht ist im grunde die gesamte
kreativitäts wirtschaft vom freien
künstler zum berufsmusiker fotografen
und designer 22 milliarden franken
werden dort jährlich umgesetzt
es geht um tausende arbeitsplätze umso
wichtiger ist dass das bundesamt für
kultur am montag informiert hat wie die
280 millionen für die kultur verteilt
werden sollen
berechtigt sind kultur unternehmungen
selbständig erwerbende und freie
kulturschaffende und ein kleiner teil
geht an die laien kultur es gibt drei
formen der hilfe die auswahl
entschädigung bei absagen die darlehen
bei liquiditätsengpässen und die
nothilfe für unmittelbare
lebenshaltungskosten das meiste geld von
diesem hilfspaket wird von den kantonen
verteilt wie zb vom kanton zürich der
die größten mittel für darlehen und
ausfall entschädigungen bereithält
für die nicht gewinnorientierte
kulturunternehmen und rousseff als
entschädigung für kultur und der name
und kultur schaffen die mit denen
instrument läuft umsätze konnte
das heißt es reicht mir ruft mir in
china um mehr machen natürlich bei
künstlerinnen wie ruth erz ist es
komplizierter vor allem weil der genaue
verdienstausfall wegen abgesagten
ausstellungen und fehlenden neuen
projekten kaum zu beziffern ist wie
durch mauricio stehlik beraten wenn man
nur ständig ob seite
das ist dann vielleicht kannst du dies
weil ich sage jetzt mal 100 bis 400 zu
zeigen
dann entstehen synergien kontakt und so
weiter das ist schwierig zu berechnen
der galerist klettert brockmann kennt
das problem und hat aus diesem grund
schon sehr früh einen solidaritätsfonds
eingerichtet private gönner können
schnell und unbürokratisch geld
einzahlen
das dann an die künstler in not fließt
damit konnte er schon über 20 personen
beträge von bis zu 500 franken auszahlen
[Musik]
das kann sie die lebensmittel
medizinische netzwerk fertigt das mir
extrem schnell reagiere das mir
rotierenden tag der autofahrer bei rot
erz geht es nicht so schnell als
selbständig erwerbender kann sie sich
bei der regulären ausgleichskasse sva
melden
doch bisher hat sie noch kein geld
gekriegt weil als freischaffende
künstlerin passt sie in kein raster über
stampfl ich hatte kurz aber noch ist das
eigentlich mini stellt die asv damen
telefonierten von ihrem musiklehrer was
ich mache also doch etwas jetzt telefon
ab und ich bin mir sicher heraus was ich
mache aus bildende künstlerin
ich meine man dort ist das doch nie
fassbar
das geld des bundes ist zwar vorhanden
kommt aber bei fällen die frau erst noch
nicht an
immerhin wenn alle stricke reißen kann
man sich beim verein swisscube sozial
melden
hier stehen 25 millionen franken an
soforthilfe bereit das formular ist seit
montag ebenfalls online
die äußeren kunstschaffende in ort
abstellen ihrer akuten notsituation sind
beim mitrivalen oder möglich auf das
konto hat und einfach nicht runter und
dann bio ist es zur stelle und dann
sollte man schnell
hoffen wir dass man ganz nach danzig
es braucht zeit bis sich die abläufe zur
beantragung von hilfsgeldern ein spiel
das die ergänzenden maßnahmen zur
rettung des kultur sektors überhaupt
gesprochen wurden zeigt die bedeutung
der großen vielfalt des kulturschaffens
ist im bund und den kantonen bewusst
wenn die verschwinden die bilder sich
nicht einfach so wieder das ist angst
und das ist die politik wieso man kultur
zusätzlich stützt oder etwas dir das die
vielfalt vom angebot was ich hätte jede
arbeit priore nutzer bildet das die sich
nicht einfach sofort regeneriere dieses
bewusstsein der offiziellen stellen
lässt hoffen dass die gelder doch noch
rechtzeitig dort ankommen wo sie müssen
auch bei rotiert
[Musik]
ja und jetzt sind wir hier drehen die
menschenleeren naturhistorische museum
ihr in bern und in diesen zeiten von
corona lernen wir ja die welt mit ganz
neuen augen sehen und auch in dieser
ausstellung lerne ich das thema
weltuntergang mit neuen augen können
dann am anfang war das ende kein
makaberes gedankenspiel im gegenteil
der titel der ausstellung weltuntergang
ende ohne ende war es mehr das
nachdenken über den untergang hat die
menschheit nicht nur geängstigt sondern
auch die fantasie beflügelt
weder ein virus unseren schönen planeten
ein ende setzen
eine naturkatastrophe
oder sind es wir menschen die uns in den
abgrund stoßen
dass die welt untergehen wird das ist
leider ein naturgesetz wie und warum das
geschehen wird das zeigt dieser
installation eindrücklich und hier kann
ich sogar selbst das kommando übernehmen
mit diesen knopf kann ich das ende
simulieren
bis das geschieht wird es noch ungefähr
sechs milliarden jahre dauern
aber dann ist schluss mit der energie
der sonne und unser planet wird
verglühen
jede zeit hat ihre eigene krankheit jede
epoche ihre eigene pandemie könnte man
behaupten
wie aber bewältigen mir solche phasen
aus einzelner mensch oder auch als
gesellschaft wir haben die menschen die
pest verarbeitet die cholera oder auch
die aids-pandemie wir schauen zurück mit
der medizinhistoriker florin conrad
wie das jüngste gericht muss es den
menschen jeweils vorgekommen sein als
sie über jahrhunderte immer wieder von
tödlichen pest wellen heimgesucht wurden
krankheit und tod gehörten zum
göttlichen plan wichtig war einzig das
seelenheil im jenseits
der mensch hat er das irdische jammertal
zu ertrag ärzte waren machtlos
das diesseits ertrug man mit fatalismus
der tod rief alle zum letzten tanz ganz
wie ihm geliebte es half nur galgenhumor
wie überliefert vom wiener bänkelsänger
augustin
alles
[Musik]
vor der verwaisten uni zürich treffen
wir den medizinhistoriker flogen control
für uns hat er sein home office
unterbrochen das motiv vom tanz unter
fotos die eine pestepidemie so viele
leute sind dass man sich ständig als
abberufung der hat mich der tod um jeden
hektar so zeigen erwartet und dass das
was tiger spielerische von der resonanz
60 geschäfte deswegen im totentanz
ästhetisch wurde will die damalige welt
so funktioniert hat
im neunzehnten jahrhundert wütet die
cholera wieder sterben millionen
doch anstelle von gott liefert die
aufstrebende wissenschaft erklärungen
irdische mangelnde hygiene verseuchtes
wasser
bald werden auch die gefährlichen
krankheitserreger entdeckt die mikroben
das dominante thema von der hohlraum 19
hat jahrhundert ist ungleichheit dass
gott für die europäische stadt und land
damaliger zeit ganz stark und fragt wie
sie mit und geschichtenband umgang mit
armut wenn du also für ganz einfache
formel bringen bewegung vom 19 hat er
100 mit der wissenschaftlichen hygiene
als leiter disziplin trinkwasser
sanierung von der stadt was sanierung
und somit das ist ein typisches beispiel
für verhältnisprävention das heißt die
vorzüge die vorbeugende maßnahme
beziehen sich auf die infrastruktur
steht beziehungslos umgebung verhalten
von den menschen wirkt eigentlich nur
begrenzt verändere durch die
verhältnisprävention
die neue erkenntnis gesundheit ist
machbar und planbar
der mensch lernt impfstoffe und
medikamente zu entwickeln um gefährliche
keime in schach zu halten
noch ein zweiter weltkrieg anderen sich
dank man dazu über sogenannte
risikofaktoren epidemiologie trieben das
untersuchte schrank hat dann in bezug
auf risikofaktoren durch das gerade
verhalten bei jedem einzelnen im
vordergrund jeden einzelnen anfangen sie
ist risiko abschätzen und das risiko
kühlbetrieb für alles wohnung macht
jeder sein eigener gesundheitscoach und
risk manager ein selbstverantwortliches
individuum das gilt sogar während der
aids katastrophe nach anfänglicher panik
findet sich die formel für den
selbstschutz
safer sex
[Musik]
weitere einschränkungen gab es nicht
keine abstandsregeln und schon gar kein
lockdown wie diese fidele aids-gala
belegt man konnte selbst bestimmt weiter
leben
jetzt ist das anders das funktioniert
coronation überhaupt nicht wenn jeder
handgriff wenn ihr die oberfläche
potenziell 35 virus dann ist fertig mit
irgendwie risikobeurteilung und die
handgelenke das land erhöht
der einzelne kann das risiko nicht mehr
selber steuern
das bedeutet entmündigung einer
majestätsbeleidigung für das moderne ego
verein schlag sie mir nehmen als
einzelpersonen unterwegs als schweine
ich ags wodurch bald laufen und
probieren da ist irgendwie realisieren
und ich finde dass im moment die ganz
große viereck mir hat jetzt als
gesellschaft 200 jahre mehr oder weniger
gelernt dass mir verantwortlich sind für
urlaubsflair trat jetzt der krise wo das
- das setzt das danke vom momentan
zumindest geschafft
gesellige freizeitgestaltung
lebensplanung das großartige versprechen
der selbstverwirklichung alles liegt
gegenwärtig auf eis diese kränkung hat
das potenzial eines nachhaltigen traumas
als sich so dass die psychischen folgen
aktuelle krise wird die werte noch die
sind schon mal da bin überzeugt und die
werden immer größer werden da muss man
abwarten und gucken was denn da genau
passiert
gegen diese kränkung helfen nur
gelassenheit und zuversicht oder wie es
früher mal hieß gott vertrauen
[Musik]
was wäre das hollywood-kino ohne
weltuntergang ohne drohende apokalypse
[Musik]
viren außerirdische naturkatastrophen
roboter sie alle wollen die welt
zerstören
auch kein film ohne politische absicht
und dabei ist er so schön so unglaublich
schön
der weltuntergang kann ja ganz lustvoll
sein wie diese ausstellung zeigt aber in
der realität sind die bedrohungen viel
banaler auf diesen glauben zeigt sich
welche veränderungen unseren planeten
tatsächlich bedrohen
wenn man die verschmutzung der ozeane
durch plastik sichtbar macht dann sieht
unsere erde so aus
die roten flächen sind die teile des
regenwaldes die bereits vernichtet
wurden
aber die ausstellung hier im
naturhistorischen museum bern zeigt
nicht nur die zerstörung
sie bietet anregungen um nachzudenken
über das weltende
diese video installation zeigt wie ein
fast-food-restaurant langsam untergeht
[Musik]
oder hier eine arbeit von julia scharia
der schweizer künstler geht dorthin wo
es wirklich wehtut da zeigt den zerfall
des bikini atolls
es wurde 1950 er jahren von den
amerikanern für atomversuche missbraucht
eine apokalypse in der 17
[Musik]
julia schilly er sucht orte die magisch
schön sind und die sich manchmal beim
genauen hinsehen als verseuchte
landschaften entpuppen wie etwa die
bildserie vom bikini atoll wo die
us-armee atombomben testete kitsch mit
weißen flecken verursacht durch
verstrahlten insel santorin fahndet
immer nach dem besonderen ort wie hier
in grönland orte die geschichten
erzählen
orte die kaum jemand betritt
weiterreisen extreme körperliche mühen
und krasse technische herausforderungen
der waadtländer geht für seine kunst an
die grenzen
man arbeitet mir die spitze technologien
also die neueste drohen
dieses licht dass selbst gebaut ist
andererseits mann überlebten der
landschaft genauso wie man das hundert
jahre her gemacht hat nun wollen wir
dann plötzlich in gründern und zwar
minus 30 grad und 30 grad zum beispiel
der gasflasche nicht mehr angehen das
ist ein muss denn wie feuer machen weil
er gas zu dickflüssig waren deswegen
können wir aber nichts mehr kochen
julia schilly er lebt eigentlich in
berlin
doch zu beginn des logins war er gerade
in der schweiz und verbringt nur die
quarantäne im engadin
wenn man schön spielst dann dann die
berge und natürlich eine riesen
herausforderung und auch also wie ein
erdbeben die eigentlich alles
erschüttert hat und man weiß ja gar
nicht wo es führt also ich meine
demokratische system funktioniert gerade
gar nicht einig wie man es zwanghaft zu
hause bleiben muss drei jahre arbeitete
karriere an seinem neuesten werk turners
lipo in dem film mischt er bilder von
verschiedensten regionen der welt 104
minuten lässt man sich ein auf den sehr
langsamen flug von island über grönland
bis in die schweiz
shari er will den typischen bildern aus
diesen regionen die in der klimakrise
schon tausendfach benutzt wurden
seinen blick entgegen setzen die
überführung von bildern die bringt oft
brice und wissen unsere möglichkeiten
und zu identifizieren oder vielleicht
auch ein ort wirklich noch ein wieso
eine emotionale link oder so ein auto
wie ein traum also der davor war er wie
ein traum und jetzt ist er in wien
trauma dargestellt und deswegen habe ich
das gefühl gehabt dass ich eine art von
alternatives sichtweise vorschlagen
musste und deswegen habe ich die
faktische nacht als bühne genommen
bekannt wurde karriere mit einer
kunstaktion die ebenfalls in der arktis
entstand sieben stunden versuchte er mit
einem bunsenbrenner einen eisberg zum
schmelzen zu bringen
auf seine art ein ironischer kommentar
zum klimawandel dorthin gehen wo es
wehtut
er ist forscher abenteurer manche meinen
ein wahnwitziger film ist ja ganz klar
als julia künstler der eigentlich gerne
auch draußen sein mag und ich glaube so
ein großteil von meiner arbeit sei nicht
die welt als atelier und das ist
natürlich etwas aus der wissenschaft der
vielleicht als feldforschung beschrieben
wird und es gibt für das nicht so ein
etikett für die kunst aber es gibt heute
so eine notwendigkeit neben den
wissenschafts auch in andere diskurs für
die gleiche themen wie zu entwickelt
wenn josh arieh er in berlin ist
arbeitet er in seinem atelier in seinen
projekten
er hat ausstellungen auf der ganzen welt
unterstützt von seinem gut
funktionierenden team
auch der einfluss seines lehrmeisters
olafur eliasson ist unverkennbar
wenn er etwa die weite der
palmölplantagen in schier endlose
montiert 75 minuten lang monokultur
carrière inszeniert den hemmungslosen
raubbau an der natur wie einen bunten
rave
auf der architekturbiennale 2012 in
venedig besprühte er tauben mit
lebensmittelfarbe gemeinsam mit julius
von bismarck ein kunstwerk das über die
ganze stadt flog eine minimale
intervention die das stadtbild verändert
seine kunst definiert er selbst als
moderne landschaftsmalerei wie
beklemmend empfindet er gerade den
zustand der welt durch die korona krise
viel größere probleme als gauner die auf
uns zukommen weil die hoffen zu kommen
nächste 20 jahren denke ich und das eine
wie eine probezeit
ich hoffe dass jeder das so sieht ist
man nicht wieder in den ernster raten
wie einspringt und einfach genauso wie
davor auf seine ausbeute leo
kapitalistische art weitergehen werden
julia schaar fordert zur
auseinandersetzung heraus
seine kunst ist einfach schön auf den
ersten blick dahinter liegt die
zerstörerische kraft des menschen sein
fataler einfluss auf die natur
auch jede private katastrophe ist so was
wie ein welten ende wenn ein herz
zerbricht dann geht eine welt unter
diese haarlocke zb die sich eine frau
abschnitt um an ihre liebe zu einem
älteren mann zu erinnern oder diese
zerstörte platte die eine trennung nicht
überlebte
der klägliche einzige rest einer
23-jährigen beziehungen
fenster auf
private herausforderungen erleben wir
alle in diesen tagen und wochen die
frage ist nur was macht diese
merkwürdige zeit mit uns antworten
darauf gibt es in einem experiment von
uns mit namen sieben künstler und ein
virus jetzt kommt folge 2 und sie
beginnt mit einer ganz besonderen art
von social distance in ein blick von
weit oben
aus sicherer distanz die tänzerin lisa
schotten skip rey hat dieses video für
uns aufgenommen
das ist mein faible zuschnappte ich am
liebsten frische luft die den unter
leuten und respektiere socialiste lisa
hortons kelbra ist eine von sieben
künstlerinnen und künstlern den zeiten
der korona krise ihre gedanken mit uns
teilen
hallo ich bin lisa tänzerin hier am
basler ballett geboren und aufgewachsen
bin ich in oslo in norwegen
ich lebe nun hier um meine leidenschaft
voll auszuleben so macht staubsaugen
mehr spaß
[Musik]
lisa hat ihren arbeitsalltag aus dem
ballettsaal in ihre wohnung verlegt
trainiert und probt hier jeden tag ich
habe die möbel umgestellt und haben an
diesen großen offenen raum um mich zu
bewegen
mein körper ist mein instrument und ich
kann jetzt das weitermachen was ich
liebe ich bin katrin koudelka mein name
ist michael von schönermark den seit
bald 15 jahren geigerin hier im tonhalle
orchester zürich ich bin solo fagottist
um tonhalle orchester zürich und dozent
für fagott an der hochschule
wir wollen konzerte haben wir wollen
konzerte spielen als musiker das ist was
wir immer gemacht haben und wofür wir
unser ganzes leben lang geübt haben und
das ist ein riesen teil von unserem
leben und von unseren persönlichkeiten
und wenn der einfach wechselt das ist
wirklich schmerzhaft
[Musik]
hallo ich bin für monika spiegelburg und
bin eine künstlerin ich glaube in zürich
bin unter quarantäne
da ich zu der hochrisikogruppe chöre und
papier vor allem ihr dann jede nacht
umsatz garnieren vorstellen dass so was
passiert obwohl ich das mitverfolgt hat
in bochum oder das kochen ist
2000 geld mal tätig sowie drei wochen
[Musik]
ein bezug zu der stadt und alles sehr
beängstigend kunde wie schnell sich das
virus ausbreitet veronika sparrenburg
schickt uns videos aus ihrer wohnung
beschreibt ihre welt und die blicke aus
dem fenster nach draußen
die stille war unheimlich aber es ist
auch ein interessantes still
komisch ich nehme ich sie meine gefühle
meine neugier und meine kreativität kann
ich nicht in quarantäne schicken kunst
das ist meine medizin
deshalb bleibe ich kreativ schreibe
zeichne singe ich mache verrückte sachen
musik und tanz veronika spiegelburg
hatte noch einen tag vor dem lockdown
für eine neue arbeit gedreht menschen
verquer auf der straße enorm spürt nur
einfach alles wieso weggerutscht
zuständige als wäre es relativ kurze für
mich sind sie wiesen klopfen und mich
stellt sich den findet das jemals stadt
macht es noch sehen überhaupt sich mit
dem projekt befassen
natürlich stellt man sich auch die
fragen die viele andere umtreibt wie
lange das noch dauern wird ob es den
eigenen arbeitsplatz
danach noch geben wird ob es so ein
kleines virus schafft 150 jahre
traditionsorchester auszurotten und ob
unsere kinder dann noch die
wirtschaftlichen folgen dieser krise
werden ausbaden müssen
[Musik]
unterricht in corona zeiten mit computer
verrotten noten bleiben gleich mikrofone
und kopfhörer und der student im
bildschirm hallo fabian
[Musik]
wir schauen ganz besonders dass erster
und zweiter finger wirklich mich
aneinander kleben die schönen platz
haben und dass auf der daumen ihr links
wirklich frei ist
[Musik]
ich habe gerade drei stunden per skype
unterrichtet was echt anstrengend ist
aber was trotzdem erstaunlich gut
funktioniert und so werden wir sofort
fahren und kreativ bleiben die nächsten
wochen
und nächste woche folge drei unter
anderem wieder mit der kabarettistin uta
köbernick ich habe da ja mit mit neugier
und mit bauchschmerzen zugesagt also das
fernsehen glaube ich muss sich zurzeit
auch echt selbst ein bisschen neu
erfinden
und vielleicht gelingt das in diesem in
diesem beitrag in diesem projekt ja wir
sehen das ende von unserem rundgang hier
natur historische museum in bern
momentan ist es geschlossen aber ich
kann ihnen versprechen auch sie werden
noch sehen diese ausstellung sie läuft
nämlich noch mehr als zwei jahren
[Musik]
nächste woche mache ich mich auf einen
zwei meter distanz spaziergang mit dem
schriftsteller peter stamm er führt
aktuell 1 corona tagebuch und gleich
jetzt geht es weiter mit der schweizer
serie kleine lügen kommen sie gut durch
die woche bleiben sie gesund ist
[Musik]
jetzt
wie
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos